[Music]
rose callie
general wants to see you
there is only one thing harder than
winning a wall keeping the peace
for the past five years we coexisted
peacefully
until now
if we don't find a solution three
billion will die
however we crack their navigation
we're embarking on the first mission to
their world
you've been blessed with the ability to
interact with alien tech
and i want you
to join us
give them a taste of their own medicine
that's it
oh so you have half a plan yeah best
ladies and gentlemen welcome to cobalt
what
anything moves
learning
got movement north wall two signatures
what is
it surrounding us
we face extermination
we'll have to push beyond our limits
i know what's at stake
i'm not afraid to die for it
[Music]
i have to finish this myself
hold on
[Music]
[Applause]
deaths continue to spiral out of control
due to the oxygen crisis that the world
has termed the sickness last year i had
20 kids in my class this year i have 12.
ethan white
do you know what your father did here
made the chronicle
what if i told you that you could save
all of us
save your wife
we received a message
from the future the future this is a
phone machine the people who sent the
message must have found a cure do you
really believe i'm gonna save the world
you're all me
you may be humanity's only chance to
finally cure 10
[Applause]
come back to me
whoever sent the message we need to find
it
at the beginning of the journey that can
change everything
you have to trust me now
this isn't that funny
there's something bigger at play
imagine that we are all connected by the
very fabric of the universe
[Music]
[Applause]
an invisible field that bonds us
together here me the stars we can't
change anything it's always going to
play out this way there is no other way
we are all connected through time
about saving the world
it's been two years since their
mothership arrived out of nowhere
an invasion force held bent on
destroying humanity
if it wasn't for a handful of brave men
and women
they would have succeeded
but now
i fear that the worst is yet to come
what i'm about to show you
has only been known to a handful of
people
this is their weapon to set this planet
up and wipe the sleigh clean this is
project rainfall
is this gonna be it
running
fighting repeat
now write a story as a spacious
it's not that we fall but that we rise
again
oh
that's not good
here we go
something big is coming
[Music]
you're going on a journey a journey
through memory
all you have to do is follow my voice
[Music]
we're closed i know i'm sorry it's late
we have time for one more job
when the waters began to rise and war
broke out
[Music]
nostalgia became a way of life
there wasn't a lot to look forward to
so people began looking back
nothing is more addictive than the past
no no no no don't put me back put me
back i understand
she has moved on and you should too
people don't just vanish
to find where she'd gone i had to know
where she'd been
we should be running from the past
or racing back towards it
how much did you really know her how
much did you look
was he who was human not with me
you think you are anxious
where is he
where is he
don't go down this path stay here in
this life
i've turned a blind eye to plenty
i have to do this
[Music]
that machine of yours
how close can you get
before the illusion's broken
you're going on a journey
all you have to do is follow my voice
you
are an infinite
evan mccauley
diagnosed with schizophrenia
at 14.
after covering the words look inside
into your chest with a box cutter
look inside
why those words
which one of these
is yours
look you could skip the whatever the
hell this is because none of that is
mine
[Music]
was it yours i don't know what you're
talking about
jesus every time you say i don't know
it's trigger guess
is it yours look i don't know are you
out of your mind
last chance evan
is
this
yours
hello old friend
oh
get in
this isn't your first life evan
you are an infinite
you've lived
[Applause]
and died
a thousand times
we're talking about reincarnation
if you can remember
who you were
you will understand
who you can become
well they say kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help
i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war
our enemy is not human
and we are losing we need you to fight
i will be back
and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world is it
all right yeah going to war stop talking
listen sorry i mean when i'm nervous i
talk i'm like 97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future
you and your unit are now in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster
and stronger than you can possibly
imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous if you like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the face of
the earth nothing we do here matters
that's where you're wrong
i don't believe that one bit together we
can stop this war
from ever happening
this is my opportunity to give this
world a second chance
second chances are really hard to come
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it in
the cabin the bullet goes in thing and
everybody's sucked out
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free
you have got to get control of your
aggression but we will get hauled off
into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is
discarnate
oh [ __ ]
where you going
that is a red one you need to come out
right now
i was meant to eat everybody
i promise oh yeah
eddie
you'd feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god so sorry i'm sorry just doing some
serious couples
we've studied outer space more than the
earth
[Music]
what happened
where are the others
everything is just like in a regular
shaft
but later on you'll see
what we actually created here
is
it's the end
of the human race
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
you have any idea what those markers are
they look pretty ancient
the tracks end here it's definitely
bravo team they don't just disappear
where the hell are we
that lightning it hit those markers and
it took us somewhere
wow
guys
so what are we like guardians of the
galaxy now
on our six
did you see that thing
go back
this is officially above my paygrade
i don't care
what those creatures are
we destroy them
and close the gateway
it's going to be a beautiful wedding
here you are standing on the precipice
of something so much bigger than anyone
here but always remember you are not
alone i don't think that we met i'm
sarah niles hi hi
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
day so far today tomorrow it's all the
same you what is going on hey get out of
the water
i guess you followed me it's one of
those infinite time loop situations you
might have heard about that i might have
heard about yeah
the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start i drove all the
way back home to austin and i still woke
up here one time i smoked a bunch of
crystal and made it all the way to
equatorial guinea it was a huge waste of
time
well then what's the point of flipping
we kind of have no choice but to live no
i'm gonna get out of this
suit yourself
see you tomorrow
so now what do we do you just have to
embrace the fact that nothing matters do
you sleep with people in here great
question i have but it takes a lot of
work yeah i got in
it's the first dance and that's a deal
breaker
that didn't work
let's waste some time
[Music]
you're right
got him
[Music]
i hope it's not all meaningless
at least you have each other nothing
worse than going through this [ __ ] alone
there's a bomb in the cake don't worry i
used to be a bomb guy stand back
[Music]
this is our only chance
we have to take it
[Music]
we need kong
the world needs him to stop what's
coming
and this child
she's the only one he'll communicate
with
i knew that they had a bond
she had nowhere to go so
i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way
khan did the same
[Music]
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here i'm at the same
opinion
the myths are real yeah
there was a war
and they're the last one
standing for greatness
no one
michael
i've known you since you were a child
you have a gift
you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
what's happening
i went from time
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing huh what's up doc
incident
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
let me get you
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
[Music]
maybe a new home could be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening
here somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that
something's coming
oh city
took the walking dead
ghostbusters we're ready to believe you
we're closed
shadow
your father is no longer of use to us
you have something we want
do you think this is a game the way we
should
we're out of time
next one you'll be dead
hoping to prevent them from finding you
what am i everything you need to know is
in
[Applause]
your remember
wake up
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land and you're descending seven
miles to the bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
this
[Music]
my
on a scale from one to ten how bad's my
rig
ten
we drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station
we even get there we walk up
we're just gonna walk with insufficient
oxygen across the bottom of the ocean
you don't know what's out there
worst idea ever
[Music]
what was that turn your lights off
what is that what is that
what is happening
there's something following us
welcome
king james
i'm a cartoon oh
i'm sorry kevin hart
[Music]
what's up doc
bring it here man
what brings you to tonewa doc
the computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell
hey what'd you do to my son
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball you want to play me in
basketball
i need to assemble an elite team
you need a dream team
i'll take it from here sam shoot the
ball
let's try that again shall we we'll get
your son back
i promise
what's happening
i look expensive
introducing the goon squad
i'm not a betting duck but my money's on
the other team
of the gym
your king
well at least we're good
oh and i almost forgot all of the tunes
will be deleted so
come on guys the tune squad doesn't give
up
if we're going out we're going out
looney
you gotta win this game and get our son
back pump up the chair let's go
i've got cops
the machine's producing multiple wiley
coyotes
[Applause]
well that happened wow
[Music]
we need a booth a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini
at halftime haters gonna hate
[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with the kryptonite bullet i'm
not joining your suicide squad
we'll see
[Music]
my court date is coming up and miss
wallace and maybe you can help me out
you're flinching in my door everyone
stand down
stand down
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in
or out
good
let's meet your team
it's okay i'm not okay
each member is chosen for his or her own
completely unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a
werewolf y'all next time
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel he's harmless i mean
he's not harmless he's killed 27
children but you know
your mission
is to destroy every trace of something
known only as project starfish
any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no
no
all right
let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
[Music]
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
ratatouille what do you got
bird now now wait stay off the comp
[Music]
how's my man
oh what no play huh
i really hope you're happy there
i'm missing you
a bit
a lot
i'm working on something
to bring you back
i've never managed to connect to
computers in the archives before
i waited a long time
and then i saw something
with you
we had a visit from the archive company
the subject is elmore julie alice
the term time so far two years eight
months four days
she's not ready to go yet of course
they think your robots might be based
around their technology we are obliged
to act with force if necessary you made
another like me i'm not replacing you
but you did it
what was she like she was perfect
i want to go home
this is home
can you hear me
do not let her outside under any
circumstances
they want you
all i have for you is a word
tenant
it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
use it carefully
[Music]
to do what i do
i need some idea of the threat we face
as i understand it
we're trying to prevent world war
iii i'm not saying are we getting here
no
something worse
i gather you have an interest
in a certain russian national
you might just bring me in
you really want to know
he can communicate with the future
time travel
no
inversion
name it and pull the trigger
you're shooting the bullet you're
catching it
oh
what i've seen too much well we'll try
and keep up
your duty transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems bold
old i'm fine but i thought we're gonna
say nuts
this is where our worlds collide
how would you like to die old
you chose the wrong profession
[Music]
well happen here
hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
i need a tenant
we need to save them here and now
this reversing the flow of time
there's us being here now
and it never happened
you want to crash a plane
went on from the air let me search
dramatic
well how big a plane
that part is a little dramatic
many homes have the pretence of being
ideal
but these homes really are ideal
it's not exactly what we're looking for
wait no no i don't think this is the
right way yeah this is the way we came
in no is it
did we just do some kind of loop
hello
i've never heard such silence
what if they don't come
what are we supposed to do
this house is
forever the perfect environment for a
young family
people like to be alone sometimes
not be with each other all the time
[Music]
this is something i could do please just
let me do
this i want to go home
that's nature that's just the way things
are
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes
choosing
between what the world wants you to be
i know you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world
i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our role
it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me
you were everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
yulia can you tell me why you decided to
help the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
do i have to answer
they're back again
you
you're in danger
you all went too far in your research we
have to get out of here
you can come back
but she must be
so this is a eliminated
attack but not from this planet
you know i don't belong here dad
everything's gonna be fine
i don't even have a passport how are we
gonna cross the border we'll have to
cook up a corruption scam
no more cell phones
no more digital technology
[Music]
help me
[Music]
and initiate
[Music]
sequences are made of this what is this
place i'm sorry to be the one to tell
you this but you got yourself killed
at rsd we'd rebuild the most important
assets in the us military
soldiers like yourself
you're the first who we've successfully
managed to bring back but improved
enhanced
with the technology in your veins you
have an army inside you
that will not only make you stronger it
will heal you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
[Music]
where are you going i got unfinished
business
i'm gonna find the man who murdered my
wife and kill him
[Music]
oh that's not good
all right sundown
and initiate sequence
[Music]
okay who is the next target for
elimination
[Music]
do you remember anything do i know you
guys i don't think so
they've been manipulating you
what you think is real
sometimes i ain't and initiate sequence
[Music]
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
i feel like i just heard this are they
playing with some repeat
good morning miss garcia good morning
sunshine i miss you
i can kiss you right now
[Music]
sunday
curfew is now in effect
all unauthorized citizens must stay
indoors
tensions rise as we enter the 213th week
of lockdown grim new reality emerges
over 23
[Music]
whoa i'm immune
[Music]
all infected americans are being forced
into quarantine camps
[Music]
sir what's going on
department of sanitation sir talk to me
i think my neighbor has a fever it'll be
so much easier if you just open the door
mrs grant you have
do not open that door
[Music]
beginning thermal scan three two one
anomaly detected armed guards will be
arriving in four to six hours you must
not attempt to leave your home or you
will be shot on site
[Applause]
i know you're in there
[Applause]
sometimes we have to do things we don't
want
to survive
i'm trying to save the one person left
in my life that matters to me
i can't help you what you're talking
about is illegal
[Applause]
[Music]
and remember stay safe
sane and sanitized
this is captain max cloud do you read
over
okay then
who wants the first dance
max cloud is here
dad playing those damn games
so i'm scared
to just play video games all day every
day
okay so
keep it together is this real can i
touch you
pull yourself together soldier we don't
have time for this what beer is not near
cowboy is here
i'm pretty sure i'm in the game i'm kind
of freaking out right now so look out
[Music]
[Music]
literally no one was shouting soon
it will
[Music]
you were fantastic
when your wives suggested couples
therapy do you think this is what they
had in mind definitely
i mean we're a couple of couples right
bill ted enough of the delusions you
didn't time travel and you didn't go to
heaven and hell
here's a real idea for you be role
models to your daughters get real jobs
[Music]
bill we've spent our whole life trying
to unite the world and i'm tired dude
dad we have a destiny to fulfill
[Music]
oh
wow greetings my excellent friends
we have a problem
step forward
a song created by preston logan
performed tonight will save reality as
we know it
oh
dude we better write that song now or
why can't we just go to the future when
we have written it take it from
ourselves
except won't that be stealing
how is cheers stealing if we're stealing
it from ourselves dude
dude our dads are totally in trouble
you should help them out
[Applause]
way
how's it going
ted
we're putting together your most
extraordinary band
hey you want to be in our band
oh this is your fantastic
we're going to go talk to death is he
playing scotch by himself dude he's
cheating hey death
well if it isn't a wild stallion
let's rock
excellent to each other and party on
dudes
[Music]
how you doing well you know dead and
we're in hell
but how you doing
we're good
look at this
all those years in the big city we
finally got out
we're living the dream
maybe
it is a dream
then everything just blew up
big flash like a pink light or actually
i don't even know what color it was it
wasn't like any color i'd ever seen
before
it looks like a meteorite
i think it's radioactive i mean it's
from space right meteorites are
generally no more dangerous than
ordinary rocks
how can something that big just
disappear did you plant those no
wart come here for a sec
oh god
what are you doing
it's talking to me
who's talking to you a man
[Music]
it's in the static it's in the moisture
what's in here is out there
and what's out there is in here now
everything's under control oh here he's
so in denial that thing from the
meteorite changes everything around it
[Music]
it's just the color
can you believe me now
i don't know what i believe anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
everything's gonna be a-okay
she was called mother earth
we plundered everything she offered
[Music]
where i'm from all reproductive
technology efforts failed for both men
and women
they want to prove that we can procreate
here
on earth
he came to earth on the first mission
we waited so long
it's imperative that we give future
generations the chance of civilization
and bring our people home
for the money
[Music]
who are they
survivors
months we called them
i saw a child
we can repopulate our planet
there are children
they won't be by the time our people
arrive
keep an eye on
my daughter
where is she
i want to help you
let's go
are you still with us blake
our predecessors failed us in so many
ways
are they coming
let's get out of here trust me
brother
[Music]
you